so let's jump right into the woke crazy
story of the day on this pride month
you know this Twitter account that I
like it's called n wokeness they put up
this image this is really interesting to
me uh Megan Fox you guys all know the
actress Megan Fox she was in
Transformers and can we say was she in
anything else besides a couple
Transformers she must have been in
something else anyway she's she's a big
Hollywood star actually uh she has three
sons that all dress like girls I'm sure
it's just a coincidence now I don't want
to make this about these three kids so
you don't even really have to pay much
attention to looking at the kids or
anything like that apparently one of the
kids according to Megan Fox identifies
as trans the other two are just dressing
like girls
book
you again you as an adult can dress
however you want and I guess you as a
parent can dress your child however you
want not I guess you can't you can but
is something weird going on here in
society is there something bizarre
happening in society there is why is she
going out of her way first up it would
be virtually impossible like
mathematically impossible for one of her
children to be trans and the other two
to be say non-binary or or one of these
other
phrases that now we all say it's sort of
like remember from a couple months back
that Disney executive when those videos
leaked those Zoom videos leaked from the
Disney meetings about the diversity
equity and inclusion thing and that one
woman said she's like I have a gay son
and a trans daughter and a non-binary
daughter and a two-spirit son and a and
it's like Lady it's just not even
possible that has far more to do with
you than your kids so what is it that
Megan Fox and I'm really not going after
the kids here I'm really not I'm not
even going after her I'm talking about
the idea broadly what is it that lends
itself so that an actress in Hollywood
wants to be out and about with their
trans son transun and then the two other
Sons dressed as girls well we know this
thing is just rampaging through Society
right now in some ways it does feel like
it's getting so hysterical that it might
burn out but you know you got to give
the devil is doing these things seem to
just keep going and going and going
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]